[Musique]
8h30 la cloche sonne à l'école primaire
de la Pointe des Châteaux à Saint-Leu
les élèves de l'unité d'enseignement
entrent en classe ses enfants sont
concernés par le handicap mental dans
cette classe spécialisée ils sont
encadrés par une professeur des écoles
et une équipe médico-sociale de
l'Institut médico-pédagogique de
l'association clerjois c'est spécifique
à l'UE l'unité d'enseignement joois il y
a des éducateurs dans la classe et en
fait on se partage les enfants sont
tantôt avec moi tantôt avec avec les
éducatrices le but de l'enseignement
spécialisé c'est de trouver les points
forts de l'enfant de les valoriser de
jamais mettre les enfants en échec de
toujours chercher le bon côté des choses
pour qu'il se sente bien et qu'il
progresse et si un enfant il peut pas il
peut pas trop bouger sa main et ben on
va pas forcer pour qu'il bouge sa main
on va trouver soit un substitut soit on
va essayer de limiter l'écrit pour
valoriser le et aujourd'hui c'est
mercredi la moitié de la classe prend la
route direction le CRES de Saint-Paul
pour une activité ludique et pédagogique
trampoline bien de commencer la journée
comme
ça to ça te
plaît laissz vos sacs pu on va faire
l'échauffement allez
go le trampoline est un projet initié
par la psychomotricienne de
l'association clerjoie l'objectif est
d'abord de développer les aptitudes
physiques et mentalesf aussi perd les
appuis de la terrestre donc il y a un
autre équilibre qui se met en place et
là donc l'enfant est obligé d' d'adapter
sa force sa posture sinon il tombe
donc ça lui permet aussi donc de faire
cet ajustement là de manière plaisante
ludique il y a pas de contrainte il va
vraiment chercher à faire des efforts à
progresser et voilà c'est vraiment très
stimulant pour lui deuxème objectif pour
cette rentrée scolaire amorcer la
rencontre avec les enfants dit ordinaire
pour un échange qui se développera tout
au long de l'année scolaire là
aujourd'hui comme c'était le premier
jour des de tous on n pas fait trop
d'échanges on a vu l'autre à côté bouger
l'autre on a vu ce qu'il était capable
de faire on n pas fait d'échang au fur
et à mesure on va échanger on va se
regarder on va se confronter et puis là
c'est vrai que pour évoluer c'est donc
ça se fera tout au long de l'année voilà
tout au long de l'année pour les parents
de ces enfants dit ordinaire cette
rencontre est vraiment bienvenue ça lu
apprendre à côtoyer tout type de
personne peut-être même à se
sentir à se sentir une missionf d'aider
de de partager et ce moi je trouve ça
très bien vraiment très bien ça favorise
la cohésion donc ça permet ENF de
connaître l'autre aussi et comme ça il
voit aussi il se rend compte de ce que
c'est qu'un handicap pourquoi il est
entre guillemets différent même si au
final ils sont pas différents quoi parce
que ben ils sont les mêmes hein oh là la
la grande qui est grande comment il
s'appelle tonï elle s'appelle ton et
elle est dans le groupe de mon Petitfils
alors
donc lui il aime bien la fille et la
fille lui aime aussi pareil donc il
s'entend bien je lui ai dit que voilà
comme c'est une enfant handicapé il faut
pas la p il faut parler avec elle
discuter avec elle mais c'est pour ça
que tous les deux s'entendent bien voyez
d'accord alors pour nous il y a pas de
souci de ce côtél de leur côté les
enfants de l' apprécient tout
autantu y a il y a le groupe des petits
là-bas tu as vu des petits enfants
là-bas ah il y a des grands il y a des
grands tu as vu ce qu'ils ont fait il a
fa des PO donc tous les mercredis on va
aller voir est-ce que tu es contente de
faire du trampoline avec les enfants
là-bas oui
oui après on a fait chacun son
Doig et
après lesr son ils ont
sauté c'est l'heure du retour dans
l'enceinte de l'école ici les enfants se
connaissent l'apprentissage de la
différence s'effectue chaque jour c'est
à l'école les réponses adéquates
appropriées en fonction des possibilités
des potentialités des élèves donc il y a
effectivement certains qui sont en
fauteuil roulant d'autres qui ont des
déficiences mental mais c'est à nous
adultes éducateurs d'apporter des
réponse pour l'équipe éducative bien
entendu c'est c'est un travail
supplémentaire c'est c'est pas anodin je
veut dire que si chacun fait un pas vers
l'autre on peut espérer on peut espérer
avoir une société un petit peu plus
juste plus équitable et que et surtout
plus harmonieuse et c'est un petit peu
la finalité de l'école en fait si un
enfant est heureux à l'école ça va
conditionner bien entendu sa vie
d'adulte future et on peut espérer avoir
un adulte
[Musique]
épanoui
in your